boy this is one of the best times to be
here in the valley if you love pizza
because the las vegas pizza expo it's at
the convention center it's happening and
there are so many great companies that
are here yeah just like you yes that's
great so yeah you know it's not just a
traditional pizza we're talking about
here we have plant-based pizzas as well
uh and it's not beyond the it's it's
it's before before the butcher for the
butcher danny o'malley here from before
the butcher here for the international
pizza expo we were making the breakfast
pizza before and it looks like it's hot
off the um grill that's exactly what it
is not off the grill and we've got a
nice
pizza right here and for the viewers at
home just real quick the the ingredients
that you use we're talking plant-based
no meat at all what did you what what is
in that right so i have a crust i
actually picked this crust up at trader
joe's it's organic uh all-natural crust
and then uh the meat is a breakfast
ground and it's 100 plant-based it's
gluten-free non-gmo real clean label
then we're using a cheese which is a
combination of of cheddar and mozzarella
type cheese and then a plant-based egg
just egg put a little oregano a little
salt and pepper on top and voila wow so
danny i mean i think people at home
they're starting to understand the
plant-based craze it's getting bigger
it's so good for your health
but the question is for a lot of folks
who are looking into transitioning
is the texture you know they're they're
so used to eating
meat and that that kind of you know that
transition can be difficult but your
product you're saying it it's got that
texture and and the industry as a whole
is changing and getting better you know
what's what's great about these products
today is they they are evolving and
getting better and better and really the
purpose behind these are to mimic animal
based proteins so people that eat
regular animal based proteins regularly
will try this and say hey wow that
that's very similar it tastes like and
why not right not so shocking difference
and that's kind of what's on display at
the international pizza expo it's what
you're you're selling it's what a lot of
other companies around the country are
selling and it'll be soon in your
restaurant in your grocery store so you
can make stuff like this on your own
absolutely so what have we got let's
give it a shot do it what do you say
happy birthday that you're the
plant-based guru here this is your jam
all right so there's there's one here
okay before the butcher you can find
this um at whole foods you said yes okay
if you're like a lot of people and you
want to go and just order it online
we'll ship it right to your house at
btbfoods.com
pretty good okay now now try that my
mouth is rolled out here
[Music]
very good okay two thumbs up a great
texture breakfast dessert
i should have thought about this before
we started eating on the air sorry
everybody it's all good don't do this at
home
danny thank you for coming in love this
international pizza expo happening at
the convention center what you're seeing
here will soon be wherever you're buying
your pizza goods i know you're starting
the trend danny thank you for being here
this morning thank you get to the
weather forecast with sherry springs
cheers pretty good stuff we'll bring it
over to you